it never had anything to do with
protecting the rights of minorities and
not offending people or being nice or
anything like that it was a very simple
thing to tell people like my ancestors
comrade this is maybe factually correct
but it is Politically Incorrect and what
that means is uh you are not adhering to
the party line right and to me the fact
that we adopted Chinese a Chinese style
response to that sort of threat
signals that we are moving in in an
authoritarian Direction and and the
thing that scared me most this is look
this is not a popular thing to say but I
think it's true at least in in our
country
it wasn't the politicians that did this
it was the people they wanted this Paul
after Paul after Paul after Paul you
know 20 of people want nightclub shut
down permanently irrespective of covet
irrespective of covert day
they want to shut down things just
because there's an opportunity to do so
uh where Mars on public transport 40 or
30 forever doesn't matter if there's
covert
you know we shot the bed and and I'm
really uncomfortable with what happened
let's talk about the Kobe thing a little
bit because uh obviously it has framed
almost everything over the last couple
of years uh I went radically
anti-mandate and pro-freedom literally
moved my entire life across the country
in the midst of it because of all of the
craziness uh I sense you're you're in a
similar spot when it came to mandates
and things of that mattered but what was
your Evolution like related uh I
supported the first lockdown in the UK
uh we didn't know what was going on uh
and we were told it was very dangerous
and while we should all be skeptical of
course of what the mainstream media tell
us in that sort of situation I do think
as a as a responsible citizen you do
have a duty to at least consider it and
remember what we were told in the UK is
this is going to be three weeks we're
going to solve the problem everything's
fine they told you three weeks three we
got two weeks two weeks they told us
either two weeks or 15 days they were
always working with one extra business
the longest three weeks in human history
those turned out to be so in the
beginning uh I supported the first
lockdown uh you know but from there I
just felt that we went in a dystopian
Direction very very quickly uh and on
the basis of data that to me didn't seem
reasonable uh we were forced to wear
these face nappies that don't do
anything uh as we know and not only do
we know that now we knew that before we
knew that before right uh and I think it
signals to me something I talk about in
the book actually
that we are importing ways of doing
business that are fundamentally
anti-western and and we have this from
the UK Neil Ferguson uh not not the
historian who we love Yeah but but uh
the guy who was essentially behind
advising the government to have the
lockdowns he was a scientist that must
have been tougher our Neil Ferguson yeah
I imagine so uh so he uh said in I think
it's a Times article that we didn't know
lockdowns were possible until we saw
what the Chinese were doing I mean what
a horrific and I think this speaks to
something else you know I I one of the
things I mentioned in in the book is
most people don't know do you know where
political correctness comes from the
term itself the term political
correctness
I don't think so the Soviet Union and it
never had anything to do with protecting
the rights of minorities and not
offending people or being nice or
anything like that it was a very simple
thing to tell people like my ancestors
comrade this is maybe factually correct
but it is Politically Incorrect and what
that means is uh you are not adhering to
the party line right and to me the fact
that we adopted Chinese a Chinese style
response to that sort of threat uh
signals that we are moving in in an
authoritarian Direction and and the
thing that scared me most this is look
this is not a popular thing to say but I
think it's true at least in in our
country
it wasn't the politicians that did this
it was the people they wanted this Paul
after Paul after Paul after Paul you
know 20 of people want nightclub shut
down permanently irrespective of covert
irrespective of covert Dave
they want to shut down things just
because there's an opportunity to do so
uh where Mars on public transport 40 or
30 forever doesn't matter if there's
covert
you know we shot the bed and and I'm
really uncomfortable with what happened
you know you know what day it was for me
that I realized what nonsense it was
because I'm I'm with you uh the first
two weeks I granted everybody a Long
Leash and I can even Grant in retrospect
I can even Grant a longer leash we were
so hit in the head it was the first time
we had dealt with this I think we've all
learned a lot and hopefully a certain
portion of us won't do it again but for
me it really was day 15. once they said
two weeks to stop the spread and we
rolled into day 15 because it changed
overnight they kept saying the new
normal and once I started hearing The
New Normal everywhere it was on
commercials it was on NBC CNN I was like
whoa whoa something else is going on
here and then that clearly bore out to
be true but what do you think that says
about human nature or the spiritual side
of what's going on here that we we
actually wanted it and from an American
perspective I don't know if it's quite
true from a UK perspective we revoted we
voted in a lot of the same people that
did this Gretchen Whitmer Gavin Newsom
the list goes on and on
well we know this throughout history I I
sort of joked uh during the pandemic at
some point that you know this is at
least the one thing that hasn't happened
yet is we haven't blamed the Jews but
but we've we did just about everything
it was just about everything else right
so when people are scared when people
when bad things are going on people you
know they the the instincts come out and
the worst side comes out and it's like
human beings you know on an individual
level when you're having a bad day all
your worst aspects of your personality
are magnified and the best ones are
dampened right and I tell you what it
was for me for me it was uh what
happened uh over BLM in the UK that
really showed me that this is uh a
complete nonsense because
we we had this first lockdown which I
and almost everybody uh obeyed to the
letter and had a lot of respect for
there was another moment when uh the sun
first came out it's a rare occurrence in
England uh and uh some some people had
the temerity to go outside on Sunday my
God uh and this was by this point it was
very clear that this virus does not
spread well Outdoors uh and I said on
Twitter that you know I think people
should be allowed to sunbathe and I it
was I I I I don't know what I could
compare it to the reaction that I got so
I thought people were starting to lose
their minds but then we saw the whole
country hadn't been having been locked
down for this entire time uh
BLM happens
and suddenly protest outside without
masks are a public health intervention
they were actually pro-public Health
that's where we were told because racism
was a bigger they're to be celebrated
there to be encouraged
if you want to live in a western liberal
democracy in which people are judged on
the content of their character
that can't happen
that that can't happen uh and and to me
that was the moment when I just went
okay this this is done and to the point
where
um you know we were I remember going to
speaking at a protest
in Parliament Square outside the the
houses of Parliament in in London uh
when they were trying to force medical
staff
to have a vaccine in order to to remain
um to remain in in their post and it's
interesting I I've never told the story
publicly or maybe no I don't think I
have
um when my wife gave birth she had quite
a long and difficult labor and they were
supposed to be at home she wanted to
give birth at home but we had to go to
hospital because it wasn't going well
and it was a long and difficult and
scary and all the rest of it but as it
was looking like you know things were
going to get really bad uh this Midwife
came in who was a higher level Midwife
than the other ones and she was like
this Angel she was incredible and she
helped my wife she give birth naturally
it was just like she she fixed the thing
it was beautiful it was amazing and
afterwards all the other midwives had
left and she was just filling out some
forms and she was asking us various
questions and my wife who was pregnant
at the time the vaccine came out wasn't
going to have it
and this Midwife was reading the things
he goes oh this asking various questions
then she said are you vaccinated and I
you know I my wife's just given birth
I'm sort of trying to look after her I I
don't want to you know but equally I I
don't want you know this medical
professional to think that we're the
wackos and whatever so I said uh well
you know we were pregnant and I started
sort of fumbling for an answer that that
will please both sides which is unlike
me uh and
um she said I've done where I'm not
vaccinated
and and we had a conversation I said so
you must have you must have not you must
have felt really bad when the government
was trying to force you to be vaccinated
and she said I was going to quit
that woman would not have been there if
the government had carried on with that
program and so for all the crap we took
for standing up on that issue
um I felt that to me was the ultimate
Vindication that that happened it's it's
a it's a story that I I really
appreciate and and think about a lot you
know and that's when you know we talked
about being brave and whatever you just
it's nonsense we just gotta we all got
to say what we believe if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell